be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
so as we get into our discussion about
this all new Thor what we're going to be
doing here is we're going to be diving
into the realm of speculation in
conjecture and as you guys know I love
this stuff I love trying to figure
things out and trying to understand
things so the reason why we're going to
be doing this is because Jason Harris
the guy who's running the show with
regards to this all new Thor has been
very tight-lipped about what's going on
here about who this new female version
of Thor is about what's going on with
this new Thor again a lot of this is
really just kind of left up to our
imaginations that I imagine over time
Marvel will go as far as to probably
give us a little more information and
ultimately divulge everything it is we
want to know about this new Thor but the
origins of how this new Thor came to be
really kind of date back to original sin
and if you guys remember our discussion
about original sin we had talked about
how when Nick Fury was fighting the
various superheroes that along the line
he had confronted Thor but what he had
done is he had whispered something to
four and as a result for lost his
ability to wield his hammer and that
really seems to be the key here that
really seems to be the key to not only
of course why does the Thor lost the
ability to wield his hammer but why but
who this new person is about why this
new person has basically undertaken the
mantle of Thor now one of the big things
here is that the name of Thor himself is
Thor Odin's son but what seems to be the
case you it's what Marvel really seems
to be doing with this new version of
Thor is it seems as though they're
simply changing the concept to where
Thor is a title and so where previously
we would have called for Thor Odinson
that in fact his name would simply just
be Odin's son and that Thor would be a
surname in the same fashion as mr. or
mrs. or or doctor or something along
those lines this seems to be a title
more or less than anything else and so
again what we do after the events of
original sin is that we find that Thor
has basically just been sitting on the
moon trying to pick up his hammer he's
been doing it for quite some time
and of course once Odin actually returns
to the Marvel landscape he confronts
Freya and asked her about what it has
been happening and that's what she tells
him that he's basically been trying to
wield the hammer non-stop he's basically
been trying to pick it up but the hammer
simply just won't respond to him in
addition we see that that Odin actually
tries to pick up the hammer but he's
unsuccessful
and with Odin having been the one who
initially put this enchantment on the
hammer
what Freya says is that is this is quite
entirely possible that the enchantment
may have outgrown the enchanter and this
I think really kind of gives us a lot of
insight into what's going on well again
with our video on for what we had found
is that initially the enchantment had
been placed so that only a person who
was worthy could actually pick up the
hammer of Thor but it seems as though
while the enchantment was was the item
that was making the decision and the
Thor was simply just an object that it
seems as though perhaps this enchantment
and the hammer have actually begun to
meld together in the sense that the the
hammer of Thor may in some capacity has
some kind of sentience in the very least
that is actually what determines whether
a person's worthy think of this as a
relationship between the I guess the
Green Lantern ring and the person of the
Green Lantern rain chooses in the sense
of the ring decides who's worthy this
hammer seems to do the same thing now
what we find at the end of this story at
the end of the I guess this issue number
one of the all new Thor is that some
woman some unknown person walks up and
picks up the hammer now what happens
here is really cool what she says is
that there will always have to be a Thor
and again this really seems to tie into
the idea that Marvel is making the title
or I guess making the name for a title
more so than the actual name of a person
but more so than that what we find is
that when she actually picks up the
hammer the inscription changes and what
happens the inscription changes from
whosoever holds this hammer if he be
worthy shall possess the power of Thor
now becomes whosoever holds this hammer
if she be worthy shall possess the power
of Thor and this just really seems to be
modeled charming in and saying that
again they're officially recognizing
this woman as being the new Thor now the
big question a lot of people have and
this is really rumors abound is who is
this woman and there's all kinds of
speculation out there there are all
kinds of theories out there for example
when this event first took place most
all of us initially thought that it was
Thor's mom but it was actually Freya who
had somehow managed to pick up his
hammer who was deemed worthy and is now
acting in the stead of Thor but this
entire three was shot to pieces in Thor
issue number four when Thor asks this
woman are you my mother and she kisses
him in return more or less answering his
question and saying that no she is not
his mother what we also find though is
that this new version of Thor seems
I guess likes the kind of confidence
that we had seen with Thor what's really
cool is that for those of us who went
back and read the original Thor comics
this was a great throwback to this new
version of four in the sense that when I
Donald Laker I guess when Thor initially
first popped up and Marvel as we
discussed in our Thor video he was
wielding the hammer but was very unsure
about it was a little hesitant about it
had his own concerns and so on and the
question being can he really master
these kind of powers this is the same
kind of thing that this woman displays
and this sense that she's not sure if
she could really mash these powers in
this degree she's not really sure if she
can really live up to the legend of Thor
now ultimately with issue number four of
the all-new Thor again with us being the
current issue we find the Thor is
basically I guess that Odin's son has
basically a taken refuge he has more or
less acknowledged the fact that this
woman is the new Thor in the sense that
he calls her that he says that he's no
longer worthy to wield a hammer because
when the two of them are fighting over
it that authority hammer and so does the
woman and the hammer responds to the
woman and not Odin's son and so as a
result here we ultimately see that she
undertakes this new role of Thor that
she seems to be moving forward with this
new role of Thor but again we're really
just kind of waiting on Marvell to give
us some more information to really kind
of tell us who this new version is but
what I'm curious about is leave comments
in the section there I guess in the
comments section with your ideas on who
the new version of four is I'm here to
see what kind of ideas you come up with
with that being said but we'll catch you
guys later peace